bonjour et bienvenue dans le studio
diagonale tv et vidéo de nouveau avec
tigran gharamian bon sortie gran
personne alors au cas aujourd'hui de
perche très important dans le tournoi
oui parce qu'on a de rendre de la faim
et tu viens de marquer un point décisif
face à et bien jour qui était ex-aequo
avec toi donc tea party est cruciale oui
il ya mis d'autres jolies et dans une
jolie partie grecque apparemment tué
quelques regrets mais je vais je vais
vous montrer
on va voir ça mais c'est vrai que je
suis quand même contente de gagner donc
à une victoire à ce moment là c'est
toujours un très important donc oui
parce que leur demande pas je crois que
christian bauer a fait match nul
il a fait mieux les ja ja marque moi je
sais pas du tout ce que ça donne ça
participe mais ces conditions très
compliqué comme mais apparemment il peut
s'en sortir peut-être avec une nulle
mais il a l'air en difficulté voilà donc
on verra bien s'il doit chercher le nul
avec tué l'un donc ça veut dire que très
certainement tu va virer en tête à
égalité avec christian bauer
éventuellement avec jean-marc de bras à
deux rondes de la fin donc voilà je vais
quand même très très bien placé pour la
fin du tournoi
alors il faudra encore bien joué donc
les yeux de rente et c'est sont les
partis les plus importants
exactement donc on y va alors tu allais
blanc oui et tu un peu 4 donc que l'on
juge les boutons ce qu'on aura besoin
voilà au calvel 4 donc y aller qu'il
joue souvent le 5
donc tu attends j'ai prise car la lèvre
trois caravanes et ses 6 rbs 5 co
vaisselle donc là on s'attend à kbc qui
joue de temps en temps la berlinoise
parce que j'en avais bu pas mal dans le
tournoi de joie
roy est en fait pour la première fois et
je ne les laisse pas en fait les
espagnols principal défaut à 4 x 4
cavani six attaques le pion au carré te
dire bien sûr ce pion est prenable ce
qui donne ça s'appelle l'espagnol
ouverte
oui en fait à quel point qu'un des
quatre mais sinon donc c'est bien
damphousse et le fos est le sept tours 1
donc je devais faire le pion très bien
et je menace france et 6 donc faut
prendre cavaliers et puis il ya les
piquets sont plantés dans qui joue
bassin qui joue pc un moment sous b3 et
ils jouent des six donc vous avez ici on
peut jouer un petit rôle
et puis ces trois dessins wayne marshall
les comptes dimanche à lille où vient
juste de déficit c3 donc ces trois tu
prépares des quatre oui donc on prépare
des quatre le coût des quatre est aussi
quand les noirs jouent des six il
protège le pion de 5 ce qui fait que le
cavalier peut aller chercher notre fonds
en allant à 5 et le fou n'aura pas de
casse de classe de seconde à la cola il
peut venir en c2 et c3 sert à la fois
pour préparer des quatre est aussi bien
pour un effet qui reprend joue petit
robe
ici il ya plusieurs cool principal ch 3
mais j'ai joué et oui h3 qui empêche le
fou et on gagne et que l'on cache 3 et
on prépare des 4 et après les noirs on
me coupe une différence
donc j'ai joué des quatre oui ça c'est
surprenant parce qu'on s'a existe donc
travail à nouveau voilà parce que l'idée
c'est que vous demande tpiy très bien
soutenu les scènes mais je n'ai pas joué
h3 donc non qui joue sous décale joffo
g4 et le problème c'est que ce cavalier
c'est lui qui faisait pression
exactement il est annihilée koala
c'est un peu l'intérêt de jouer h3 pour
éviter ça donc la case des cats et
légèrement attaque et non plus aux 3 et
oui parce que là ils menacent puis on
prend puis on prend vous pouvez rallye
d'europe centrale ça c'est pas bon train
et on n'a pas peur d'eux auquel il prend
un carton kaman prend 1,4 comme ça
existe mais la foule des services ou des
ces attaques
pouf pouf les deux gangs a attaqué il ya
je crois qu'il ya une façon de s'en
sortir mais pas pouvoir tout
tranquillement qu'on ici les morts
peuvent jouer encore plusieurs coups
terminé à cinq a été deux fois que ça il
a joué bd d'abord pas il a d'abord pris
en dvd cd et cavaliers à 5 donc intact
le fou le plus fort recul en c2 normal
c'est aussi les noirs peuvent jouer
plusieurs cook avait laissé quatre et
cinq dessins tout les choix
il a joué ses 5 600 îles et profite
toujours pareil cas ducloy augmenter la
pression sur la case centrale exact bon
par contre les noirs quand il libère le
pion c5 qui sont toujours obligés de
placer deux cavaliers sur las casas un
oui du coup la pression sur des cats et
les jeunes pros mortifère et qui
reviennent après donc là j'ai joué h3 je
crois que c'est toujours la théorie
voilà d'accord donc si les noirs
prennent en f3 d'un point f3 et
l'ambiance est peut-être un tout petit
peu mieux pour moi peur de tout perdre
de fouet puis un peu plus de peut-être
l'espace donc faut attaquer et le bon
coup et si je me rappelais pas
exactement ce que j'avais regardé les
blondes peuvent jouer plusieurs coups
mais la régie 4g 4g si c'est peut-être
ça risque de transposer et cavani dont
les deux qui est un coup assez typique
jeune homme ne m'a pas plu à cause de
pions prendre des quatre à cause de
pions 30 des cas d'objets de prendre du
fouet et canalis et si c'est le cas il
revient à ces six attaques dans le foot
j'ai pas vu un truc qui s'y met
ça te plaisait pas parce que si jamais
je recule de fouilles à penser 3 savaria
b4 examen des seins que le cousine et
notre jeu de dessin que je pense qu'ils
ont un problème
et oui parce que sinon je sais quel
réalisateur et peut-être qui j'ai loupé
un truc mais je voyais pas ce que je
devais jouer les noms sont libérés ici
mais une fois que le coût des 5 arrivant
ici a rien de concret derrière donc tout
va bien on s'attable et ben du coup j'ai
joué qui fait le coût principal deux des
cinq dessins voilà tu bloques nous voilà
c'est une autre ligne donc tout a décidé
de bloquer et en français donc je prends
beaucoup d espace
est-ce que ce qui est assez comme gênant
la position ressemble un petit peu de
structures de benoni sauf que les noirs
ont déjà joué à 6b 5 ce qui est une
bonne chose donc toute l'idée de cette
position là les blancs vont à tout prix
essayer de bloquer un peu en fait le fou
h5 jeu contre on se fou pour y jouer
essayer de jouer contre le fou donc les
morts ont l'occasion de faire [ __ ] en
cavalier mais après peut-être que mon
jeu sera quand même un peu plus facile
avec la paire viper de phu tho sibilité
d'ouvrir le jeu par osei le tas et il a
joué cavalier c4 et c4 attaque
le foot est roi et le pion ville de
sousse et 1 c'est tout à fait normal on
recule oui on recule donc je m'emballe
au chat c'est parce qu'on a eu peu de
chasse et oui dans certaines positions
on peut le chasser après donc les noix
avocats rennais éviter c'est donc un
nouveau théorie déjà je sais pas du tout
ce que ça donne ça a l'air content parce
qu'on se dit sûre ccca ces ultis et
harry plan réussisse le cac valeo perd
les 11,5 donc c'est vraiment un très
très logique et du boucher au budget 4g
4 donc élise faut donc je prends
beaucoup taux risquent aussi une commune
astruc structure de pions de gérer un
peu affaibli quand tu as quand même
quatre pions ici contre
cinq peintres cas donc il ya une
majorité ici qui pouvait les embêter
peut-être l'espace en même temps j'ai
mon roi qui est légèrement affaibli ici
oui mais bougez 6ème bloqué donc c'est
un peu toute la partie se jouera là
dessus donc le g6 par exemple j'ai des
idées comme car balayage de f4 f5 voilà
qu'à visage de f5 demi-fond et des clés
noires doivent sauver ce fou las
en général c'est il doit ils sont
obligés de faire une concession ou bien
les six qui donnera beaucoup d'eux qui
frappe
donc il ya ceux qui renferme beaucoup le
fou les cases ou 1,6 à noter aussi que
manger qu'as tu à empêcher la poussée
système utile pour pas que les noirs
puisse ouvrir la position donc en fait
ces positions la strate sont très
compliquées stratégiquement je sais que
j'avais déjà un regard dans ce type de
position les l'ordinateur il est il
absolument
il sait pas faire il sait pas jouer il
préfère toujours les noirs alors qu'en
réalité c'est c'est très compliqué pour
les noirs de trouver un plan quoi ils
sont en attente ont beaucoup aimé mon
ordinateur il préfère quand même des
noirs donc foulée 6 le terme à niveler
d2 donc j'essaie de d'éliminer ce
cavalier là qui gênent prise prise fo
propre internautes dans wii comprend des
oeuvres bonbons hallyday toujours joué
contre le fu g6 donc ça n'a pas changé
on s'est peut-être d'un jeune f406 way
attaque de deux attaques bttours b1 donc
tranquillement je sors aussi de
bougez la tour de ces diagonales là pour
avoir des baies 3 dans certaines
positions peut-être détroit pour
contrôler les conséquences en poche il
est l'époux c'est donc moi c'est si la
partie très très complexe par les autos
et vite je pense que c'est très bien
joué et on évite donc aussi si un jour
je tente qu'un balayage de f4 f5
je sais qu'il y aura deux fous des
cartes et chèques donc ah oui dès le
début je me suis dit allez roigé de sa
légitime
l'orangé douce pour éviter des échecs à
éviter un jour voilà ce que quand le
pion arrivée f4 f5 gymnase toujours le
fouet
si les noirs veulent libérer le fou g6
ils sont peut-être objets jouets f67 du
coup il faut une formule fouet york ça
sera pas avec un gain temps sur l'europe
voilà ils vont aller vite mais gagnent
le droit j'ai deux il a joué tour c'est
ces huit plusieurs coups était à nouveau
possible très bien supporté ses pions
trois contre deux camps mais là j'ai
décidé de laisser un peu les choses
cavale et gérer un or nous a dit aussi
que l'alliage 2 oui mais c'était très
concret ce que j'ai joué latéral les
jeunes légèrement passif mais
concrètement c'est important et là je
veux soit 4 par la menace commune iv
lesquelles nous fout et puis on prend
beaucoup d'essais f4 stratégiquement
c'est déjà très bien pour les blancs et
puis on peuvent aussi menacé rachida
comme toujours c'est pour ça que je me
disais moi le club je sais pas où j'ai
c'est bon il peut même venir injectables
par mois je
montrer pourquoi d'accord coquillages au
chaud h4 pourra empêcher s4 on peut pas
trop faire puisque le tatouage est
répété une fois calmé les trois forfaits
m6 à l'if3 faut aussi s'il n'y a pas d'
alger 1
il est revenu il est revenu ce qu'ils
ignorent qu'il est content avec la nul à
défaut ils allaient mort seul sait
n'aime pas qu'on est content ce que
c'est normal que je pense que c'est le
meilleur coup à jouer donc va cogner ça
m'a pas surpris du tout ils auraient
peur cours normal après si je répète une
fois peut-être qu'il va réfléchir mais
bon j'ai les noms je suis obligé de
tenter quelque chose
dr au dos c'est pas un conflit j'aurais
bien aimé jouer mais bon c'est la vie
oui mais bon on se dit oui à lui marc
hayek six cavaliers six attaques que
trois fois le pion de 4 et voilà donc
pas un problème sur 4,3 donc désigné
patron soit on fait alors donc
l'explication de cavani g1 et que si
lecavalier t en h2 oui dans la même
position les noirs joue cavalier prendre
des cinq le prendre de 5 400 tours pour
prendre pour et j'ai un bon mois et 1
dames 3 forcé puisque le clip est en h2s
est faussée de est en prise et le fou
ces deux étant poussé la fouge ses
passagers les laisser la différence
c'est que le calaisien protège la torodo
donc en cas de qualif rang des cinq
pions prendre tout reprend évidemment le
cavalier et on garde à la dame à la
production sinon j'ai toute la place
il me manque des cavaliers comme
légèrement mal placé un géant mais bon
c'est joli et moto noire on fait aussi
pas mal de concessions donc ma structure
de pions et hyper solide et si j'arrive
à faire quelques coups d'amélioration
comme activer la tour en b1 améliorer l'
fou des dehors améliorer aussi la dame
je peux potentiellement aborder des
menaces par la suite je sais trés comme
ça peut arriver
d'accord parce que le carbone et m6 ou
g6 tout est bloqué il faut acheter un
petit peu hors jeu aussi louise très
compliqué en fait pour l'ensemble des
étapes dans le vide mais je pense que
c'est quand même plus ou moins correct
il a joué tous ses 7 c c'est pour
essayer d'oublier un doublé sur la même
planète que je jouais fou ah non pardon
le tour de ce nom il a joué ici ça c'est
la wii d'abord si c'est vrai il a
d'abord conçu compréhension de ce soit
le bon coup mais oui je m'attendais plus
à dante cette machine touriste ménages
oui mais ça qui sont hélas j'ai une
petite soit 4 a aussi une case de angers
bon j'ai joué faut être quatre je me
suis dit bon il se protège oscillations
je me suis dit il faut que je place se
fourrer ce 4 c'est l'amendé york à la
voilà je repense quand j'attaque le pion
des six ça libère un tout petit peu les
cases pour madame la dame contrôle des
scènes
l'option qu'il ya toujours un peu
apprise donc toute la partie cette
colonne a été toujours important à
suivre
nous pas se prendre un territoire ne
passe jamais se prendre quelques points
du set
donc c'est pour ccn d2 donc maintenant
table dédiée aux petites feuilles
concrètement ça marchait pas que
deviendront ces os est donc la mémoire
si vous voulez tout les pieds sont plus
ou moins bien placé pour l'ouverture du
jeu mais c'était pas s'inventer paris
n'est pas c'est le seul problème on
marque beaucoup beaucoup potentiel à
l'oeuf ou g6 cavale et si cela plaît il
n'y a pas de plan pour faire des
ruptures voilà pour donner une pièce
quoi si pour ça j'étais obligé de
toujours surveillée qui est pas de
sacrifice donc j'ai joué un coup un peu
courte prophylactique tour t1 ou alors
ça c'est très joli parce que là on a
envie de presque 2 prendra six parce que
malgré les feux n'a pas bien fait il ya
qu à vaisselle et
dr john c'était aussi pour préparer et
puis voilà pour sûr protéger ceux qui
ont des seins il ya toujours un peu en
prison avait l'idée de prendre ici les
dames fois on vous prend dans des sacs
de la tour ne trouverez pas la colonne
oui la décanale secours toute la partie
c'est je veux pas rouvrir une colonne de
en tout cas qu'on s'accroche pas et là
je pense qu'ils se trompent pas et si
d'amd si c'était un mauvais coup on se
dit l'a pas vu fou prend 1,6 il n'a pas
bougé jamais aussi fourrage de
j'hésitais avec le planchot h d'heure et
puis dans 9 cas pour aller frapper
attaqué depuis on décide que c'est aussi
intéressant en s'intéressant aussi
bancaires mais bon faut acheter ce matin
valérie savait n'atterrisse saveurs
naturelles ozil a raté ça il a raté donc
il ya vingt thèses que qui pensait avoir
calmé prend le 4 à oui il ya exactement
la même idée de libérer d'une case de
retour en f 6 ouais et donc en fait il a
juste oublié que j'ai fou prend 1,4 qui
est très important sous prince et
papillon prendre assez justement fou
prend et par exemple le style et nous un
jour j'ai h
maintenant j'ai h et damas six dans
prend 6 donc le fou hk tête en prison
foued sicilia fou proche de 6 ans les
méthodes
c'est pour ça la fout france que si j'ai
loupé le 4 c'est un peu plus compliqué
mais là tout reprendre deux cavaliers
prendre deux tours de roue en f1 la
mairie de menthe et samat avec les noir
une blanche
les blancs par damart cette nuit d'un
match 7 à mettre 7
donc il ya juste s'il a raté sa et du
coup là je pense que c'est déjà
compliqué car elle est proche des cats
qui a été jouée mais
eric à l'étranger car il nous il est
libéré ce qu'il a joué c'est
probablement ce qu'il fallait faire
parce qu'il va perdre un pion mais au
moins donc puis enfin sauf l'eau et
surtout quasiment il est horrible 1
enfin bon temps tous les pions sur les
cases blanches c'est un peu normal que
mes caisses noires sont les gersois un
peu affaibli donc quand tu reprends a
jugé qu' on prend un fou d'un pion prix
comprend et maintenant même s'il
reviendra il ya un plan plus mais la
paire de fous des galons au kef où le
système est mauvais le fou est mauvais
mais l'hôte il est très fort celui-là
est traitée nantes parce que tous les
pions sont sur blanc tu n'as plus de
fous de casse noir oui on conseille j'ai
peut-être aucun ami qui m'a peut-être
venir pour m'aider donc le tout vers un
hommage au football pour défendre le
pion b2 au cas où la tour un oeil sur b2
puisque le fou et 6 tape dessus
actuellement
là il nous a joué six toros pas ta
passion que se soit opposé à l'entente
auquel je dis n'importe qui n'a pas joué
4 il a joué ses 15 ans le mandat courant
donc ça c'est un bon coup à sa ferme
beaucoup il lui quoi qu'il advienne il
allait devoir jouer ce coup là
la dame ces actifs qui fixait la
faiblesse en bundle dans certaines
positions et oui je fasse un peu
attention on ouvre la bouche donc que
j'active mais mes pièces qu'à l'aller h
30 il entre enfin dans le jeu il veut
venir et fils aîné bref car à les
attaquer le fou donc la wii puis là
c'est ça saute pas ce que ça va si
lloris est mon avis tu peux rien leur
arriver
le sénat doit être gagnant je
l'impression ça devait être tour 5 5 qui
allie des deux d'empêcher cavale f4 où
il y aura que tu te fous j'ai sonné
gênant qui attaquent la dame et le
cavalier ou joey damage 2 mais c'est
quand même gênant et j'ai joué cavalier
et footeux du coup l'idée c'est de juste
jouer f4 f5 comme un peu toute la partie
donc le quart allait bien pour que je
soutenir soutenir aux quatre se sont
donné le câble et en f4 en plus on
libère un peu la colonne h ça peut aider
si jamais m
f 5,6 vient cette série de fausses
interviews fini tout a changé cette ça
c'est bien joué donc voilà chasse la
dame je joue et à acheter des titres you
say jadot jours j'essaie de contrôler un
peu les cases noires toujours ce que
j'ai fait pièces et les forces oui moi
comme toujours il donc je pensais qu'il
y avait un coup à commettre cinq mais il
m'a dit que ça marchait pas après la
partie me disent ça a l'air intéressant
qui avait j il y avait quatre très
précis et j'avais vu et fait 4 mais
s'est trouvé en escale tours 7
parce que là si on prend cette fois par
le fou je ne peux pas reprendre s'il ya
une tour en prison au caire et quatre
dans ce cas là où 500 way s'est passé a
dit qu'il y avait eu cinq verges avait
absolument pas du tout c'est évidemment
sur le fond entre aussi dans le jeu avec
son père et où il le faut bien contrôler
5 si on prend et on perd le frein
salama narines je pense qu'il a raison
ça il n'a pas joué mais moi je voyais
pas que l'idée ce n'est pas de reprendre
le 5 mai c'est vraiment efsa m'y
attaquer donc est ce assez souvent il a
raison et donc du coup il m'a joué tour
5e set
taureauque 7 donc si vous voyez c'est
déjà le pas la première fois où la
colonne eu la colonne de toute la partie
j'ai fait attention à cette colo 2 que
ça nous ouvre pages et des pièces qui
traîne derrière tout est là j'ai joué
damas trois dames ans je me suis dis
jamais liant ces dames comme sage et
empêche les histoires de f5 plus d'une
semaine pour se comprendre vous prendre
dame prend pas les jours sous des 4 as
beaucoup de tours h un envoi avec les
malades m
mon corps ne sera jamais tourache un
manchon on voit la défense on sait
jamais s'ils avaient des masques à 5
oui la concrètement je menace le 5 parce
que aussi les noirs imaginons que les
noirs
à saint calais 25 et 5 et aux menaces le
dame h rythme parce que le film ne
contrôle pas et si les noirs prennent
1,5 et simplement on prend le fou et on
peut plus empêcher le match est fini si
ça donc ça fait autant
donc il m'a joué sous g7 alors ici il a
joué fou tour à chaque coup j'essaie
pardon surtout rachat ou la jet set il
ironisé set j'ai rejoué tour des airs
puisque j'étais quand même un peu dans
cette note
oui donc pour répéter un peu le coup
food et 84 en fait il se fout des quatre
pour empêcher f4 peut-être ça n'empêche
pas mais peut-être n'y va pas de deviner
cavaliers si ça doit pas marcher parce
qu'elles sont le fou et c'est être
compliqué ça allait oublier aux 400
coups que j'ai rejoué tourache un chien
mais là il a une a failli de jouer le
coup qui permet tout de suite dans le
zag notes et il a failli jouer f6 ou
donc dans la partie noufou s'est
retrouvé derrière la chaîne de pions
donc là il avait l'occasion d'abord se
fout extrêmement actif c'est alors un
salon mais il y avait damages si ça j'ai
beaucoup j'espérais qu'ils attaquent le
fou cases blanches et g7 allait tour g7
est mauvais parce que j'ai un très bon
coup le 5 à imaginer autour j'ai cette
c5
quand le choix au cje et jade est le fou
g6 où le fou b1 attaque le fou g6 il est
obligé de prendre et si prend la
majorité chèque ou la 3g 3f 7 et ie 6
échec à la guerre et aux soldats perdus
tout c est donc si on prend encore
bouillard il a tourné à sète est perdus
c'est même peut-être m'a tout de suite
en s est bien plus ce matin de 17
parce qu'il y aura des gens pour qu'ils
arrêtent et non tenues et j'espérais
qu'ils qui passe malheureusement où il
fait pas et 6 il allait rejouer le g7
il est revenu oui il protège ses cases
il protège ses cases noires près du rang
à 1 500 f 4 mai à suivre donc mais aussi
un peu l'occasion parce que les f4 je
menaçais le 5 il ya la partie tout de
suite oui avec le coup j'essaye donc il
est obligé de jouer
m6 c'est le second sas et j'y suis allé
parce que c'est ouais c'est le cas elle
pourrait prendre le cas je suis à mon
sixième défenseur donc il est obligé de
jouer ensemble c'est pas bon parce qu'on
est quand même un peu plus apparemment
c'est dans cette position il y avait un
gain claire et l'egypte a écrit à
trouver pourtant on nous a été déterminé
j'avais 9 5
f5 fo snj ont pas la garde et f5 d'une
civière cette période j'ai toujours
calculée d'un match 7 g 5 mais c'est
vrai que la dame qui ont mal placé a oui
bonjour gsm tout ça j'aurais dû jouer et
c'est la menace g6 et s'il prend il
semblait j'ai toujours le problème avec
ceux qui ont des seins qui est prise
mais concrètement ici c'est pas très
grave
c'est pas très loin puisqu'il n'ya pas
d'échec après j'ai pas grand chose et
effectivement tu montes j'ai vu la même
position avec la guerre dans la
chaussette et le rolland l'a écrite et
ça na pas papa pas trop paru claire
n'est pas aussi fort des réfugiés 8 faut
prendre des cinq est effectivement comme
ça c'était beaucoup beaucoup plus clair
parce que la f6 menace et si c'est une
grosse menace qui termine la partie je
pense que ça aurait été la fin de la
partie est bon c'est un peu de ma chute
j'ai pas vu bien que je ne sois pas vu
ça nager j'ai joué autour des 1
donc tu revenir mais je suis revenu en
d1 je me suis sûr protéger à nouveau le
pion des 5 et le temps aux agents du
hello j'étais content de ce qui s'était
passé mais je vous ai fuite
et là je sais que je peux gagner un pion
la f5
j'y suis allé et 5 donc là je voudrais
s'ils jouent faut s est maintenant j'ai
cinq cavaliers g4 s'est tout de suite
terrain mais plutôt rage cet internat
terre tour intermédiaire attaque la dame
et dames c3 je vais te dis bon allez
deuxième pion c'est toujours bon à
prendre ça peut pas être mauvais
deux régions où est attaqué ainsi que le
26 et ils jouent donc vii quel champion
des champions
bon je pense que ça doit être gagnant
donc non je sais pas ce que c'est
l'évaluation mais ces jeux d'eau qui ont
plus et là cela sera d'ici là que ça
s'arrête ou non pas encore un don qu'il
me joue faux cette poussette
je pensais que c'était déjà mauvais
parce que mon ceux que j'ai joués je
pense que c'est fini tu lis dame c3 par
le point qu'on se dit quand même quand
on voit ça dans tous les cas c'est tout
ça et c'est ben ouais je m'étais dit que
j'allais quand même y arriver là il
arrivait à passer chez ça oui mais parce
que sinon si on ne peut pas il se balade
dans fait et il faut bien faire il dame
c3 c3 d'amd 8
voilà il surcontrôlés glace noire et on
se dit est plus de loin je voyais que la
hausse axa gagné sur le champ et je
jouais centre de réflexion puis on prend
le sens il a abandonné ici il abandonne
ici ça c'est important à voir parce que
ça te paraît pas si clair pour moi
c'était très clair dans la partie pour
nous deux c'était très très claires
puisque on regardait 2.65 tort de
prendre 5 et f6 finalement le fou entre
dans le jeu et je m6 et le fougueux
intégralement très content parce que
c'est une belle diagonale a ignoré
toutes les huit cases un pouf pouf pouf
pouf attaque la tranche 7 et en plus on
attaque le foulage et j'avais vu fou
prend 1 6% faut prendre si souvent h 16
h 7 et cavaliers de quatre heures d'un
f3 s'est complètement perdues volées ou
quatre il est blanc aligne donc ça
c'était la ligne je voyais pas comment
il pouvait éviter et donc ils abandonnés
çà me parait c'est super ce moment là ça
me paraissait normal eco normal
on nous indique qu'il est quelqu'un avec
les analyses d'ordinateurs parce que
nous on n'avait pas du tout envisagé
d'accord et il y avait un contre que ça
super qu'il faut epci ce que nous
voulons c'est que toute la partie je
faisais attention à son courage sur la
colonne e et pendant un instant j'ai
oublié il y avait c'est extrêmement fort
parce que j'ai qui adoube clouage sur la
colonne de son père à tour et si jamais
l'idée de fouet si c'est que ça empêche
le coup aussi on serait complètement
gagnant 2,6 gagnent la dame est donc
mais là oui oui on va pas vraiment les
plombs c'est un petit peu mieux mais ok
c'est ça c'est n'importe quoi ce que tu
fais dans cette position j'ai aucune
idée
j'étais choqué quand on m'a dit qu'il y
avait un couvent comme faut être si ces
salaires quand même toujours fort parce
que je mangeais l'impression qu on prend
monde dont la qualité est après j'essaye
un ennemi interne des sites à oui oui ça
serait classé grassi clair il faut
protéger le cavalier et en plus il peut
y avoir des tournants c'est aiaiai la
wii c'est dangereux g3 et tout prend f2
à autre chose à faire mais c'est
beaucoup c'est un gage que toute la
partie malgré ça gâche un peu la suite
du coup j'étais un peu chanceux qu'ils
abandonnent mais honnêtement mini lui ni
moi n'avions pas vu pendant la partie
sans me paraissait complètement perdre
donc non c'est comme ça et on a vu que
tu as raté la suite gagnante avec ses
d'accord donc c'est intéressant parce
que même les grands maîtres arrivent
avant l'événement en fait puisqu'il voit
rien ce serait fou c'est trop fort sa
partie je faisais attention je suis
rentré j'ai pions la case f5 le pion des
5 et clouage vers la fin je les ai
oublié pourtant j'étais plus du tout aux
actes donc étudié en fait c'est assez on
l'a vu là tu viens de le montrer parce
que je n'avais pas vu tu me l'a dit
avant de venir dans l'émission qu'il y
avait ce coup qui sauvait un peu les
noirs mais bon essayer encore du jeu il
faut faire attention au projet est bon
c'est vrai qu'il y aurait pu tenir plus
eh oui après ça ça aurait été très
généreux
l'an passé je jouais 50 ans je gagnais
en fait finalement peut-être marais de
la meilleure ligne c'est juste laisser
ce pion aux cinq quoi ce qui est un peu
ses bêtes quoi oui mais je sais comme si
je donnais un pion comme sakho mais bon
mais comment et quand une belle partie
bon oui mais c'est c'est le résultat du
coup et le résultat le résultat surtout
d'un tournoi est très important puisque
tu marques ce point est urgent ou à la
tête du tournoi
mais on va l'avoir un peu mais donc bon
bah ils resteront de en tout cas quoi
qu'il arrive maintenant tu auras fait un
beau tournoi quoi tu auras créé fait un
beau chemin d'un faut continuer la
partie s'arrêter là il continue et un
corps qui est orienté est là tout peut
arriver
ouais bravo au tigre had merci merci
merci d'être venu dans ce lot de canal
tv pour la deuxième fois tu es devenu le
premier joueur à faire ton choix en
avant d'autres parce que
reste vivante où l'élite il y en aura
d'autres merci beaucoup merci nous avoir
suivis pour de nouveau donc cette super
analyse avec le très sympathique grand
maître tigran gharamian donc il fait un
très beau championnat et cette
magnifique partie et que yannick gozzoli
aurait pu y voyez il a encore toujours
jamais c'est une grand mère qui disait
faut jamais gagné d'actifs dernier de
sortir d'abandonner il a dû abandonner
honnêtement c'était difficile à voir
maintenant quand on connaît le pouce
c'est facile c'est facile mais sur le
coup il n'ya pas pensé du tout merci à
tous et à bientôt donc pour une nouvelle
émission de real tv 50 en 2015 au revoir